[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد
شهده سعر صرف الدينار العراقي المتراجع
بالفعل منذ نحو شهرين وفيما سعر صرف
الرسميه المثبت هو
1470 دينارا مقابل الدولار الواحد وصل سعر
الصرف في السوق الى
1620 اي ان العمله العراقيه فقدت نحو عشره
بالمئه من قيمتها رئيس الوزراء العراقي
محمد شياع السوداني قرر رائع فاء محافظ
البنك المركزي العراقي مصطفى غالب من
منصبه وهو المحسوب على الصدر وقام بتكليف
علي محسن العلاقه المقرب من المالكي
باداره البنك المركزيه بالوكاله كما احل
السوداني مديرا المصرف العراقي للتجاره
سالم جواد الجلبي الى التقاعد وكلف بلال
الحمداني لاداره المصرف وفقه وكاله
الانباء الرسميه السوداني قال ان ارتفاع
سعر صرف الدولار لم يكن قرارا حكميا ان
اليه تم الاتفاق عليها بين المؤسسات
الماليه والبنك المركزي هذا ويعزوا خبراء
تراجع سعر الصرف الى بدء العراق لامتثال
لقواعد دوليه فتحويلات الملكيه اثرت على
عرض الدولار في السوق في حين يحمل
السياسيون الاجراءات التي اتخذتها الخزانه
الامريكيه لمنع انتقال الدولارات الى
ايران
مسؤوليه هذا ترهشه
استجابه لطلبه كان مديرا للدائره
القانونيه في البنك المركزي العراقي قبل
تعيينه محافظا للبرد ترشحه في المناصب
كافه
الطيار الصدري علي محسنطلاق محافظ البنك
المركزي بالوكاله شغل العلاقه منصب محافظ
العراق في صندوق النقد الدولي 2014 شغل
منصب محافظ البنك المركزي بالوكاله حتى
عام 2018 تقلد منصب رئيس مجلس محافظ صندوق
النقد العربي منذ 2020 محافظه العراق في
الصندوق ترشحه الى المناصب كافه
الدعوه المالكي
وناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفي من بغداد
الدكتور عدنان سراج رئيس المركز العراقي
لتنميه الاعلاميه اهلا بيكوا من اسطنبول
الدكتور عمر عبد الستار المحلله السياسي
العراقي اهلا بكم واسمحالي ان ابدا من
اسطنبول معك دكتور عبد الستار هل موضوع
تراجع سعر صرف الدينار العراقي موضوع
اقتصادي خالص ام انه وبكل مصداقيه هذا
الموضوع هو الموضوع مترتب عن اضطرابات
السياسيه
يعني حياكم الله يعني انا اعتقد هذا
الموضوع له علاقه بالحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيا اولا وب حروب ايران بالمنطقه
ثانيا
وباعاده ايران على باستخدام الدولار
العراقي في تمويل كل هذه الحروف في وقت
التعثر الاتفاق النووي من جهه وفي حين
الامور تتصاعد هناك في الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه ولا يمكن للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه خاصه بعد مقتل سليماني والمهندس
وهذه تداعيات ان تقبل باستمرار ذهاب
بالدولار العراقي لتمويل الحروب ايران من
هنا انا اعتقد المساله مو البنك الفيدرالي
دخل سيادتك واللي هاي سياسه موجوده من
2003 من جاب بريمر الحقيقه لكن الان
الحقبه الدوليه تغيرت فلابد ان تتغير
السياسه المشكله في الطرف الثاني الذي
يهرب الدولار
عن العراقين
ويموت بها الحروب المشكله هنا لماذا لا
يتوقف تهريب الدولار من هنا جاءت الصدمه
الاولى صدمه بالمناسبه هذه بسيطه يعني
هناك همم اموال تذهب البنك بيع 200 مليون
كان سابقا الان ربما وصلت ل 60 مليون
لانهم خفضوا الى تقريبا 75% لكي يحصل على
دنانير لكن الدولارات هذه تذهب الى ايران
فرد منصه الكترونيا فانا اعتقد هذه خطوه
اولى المنصه اعتقد ستفشل وسيذهبون باتجاه
يعني
سنعود لنتائج ولكن دكتور عدنان
السبب الرئيسي هو تهريب الدولار كما قال
طبعا الجانب الايراني هل تتحمل ايران
تراجعه ثابت صرف همم العراقي
انا اعتقد انه مثلا بهذا الشكل يعني بعد
التحيه لك والمشاهديك الكرام انا اعتقد
المساله ليس مساء سياسيه انما مساله يعني
ماليه وليس قضيه او ازمه اقتصاديه هي ازمه
ماليه حقيقيه تتعلق بمساله صف الدولار
العراقي وعلاقته
بالبنج الفدرالي الامريكي وايضا علاقته في
عمليه تنظيم
الحوالات العراقيه الى الخارج من اجل
الاستيراد المواد الضروريه العراق العراق
سنويا في سنه
2021 استورد من الخارج ومحول الى الخارج
ما يعادل 58 مليون مليار ايه دولار امريكي
همم ايران حصلتها من هذا المبلغ خمسه
مليارات و850 مليون دولار تاتي تركيا في
الاجانب الاكبر 14 مليار دولار وبقيه
الدول العالم التي يستورد منها العراق
فالقضيه لا تاخذ فقط المبالغ في تهريب
العمله العراقيه في الخارج لانهم ماذا
يستفيد في تعريف هذه الرمز فقط كذا
الموضوع يتعلق بسعر الدولار لماذا اذا
ارتفعت همم بعض العملات منذ نوفمبر الفائت
همم حينما تراجع الدولار هناك العديد من
العملات في العالم التي شهدت ارتفاع الا
الدينار العراقي
يتعلق طلب البنك الفدرالي الامريكي من
العراق ان يكون دقيقه في مساله الحوالات
الى الخارج وهذا ما تم الاتفاق فيه ان شاء
الله منصه يعني تتحمل حكومه السيد كاظم
والمحافظ المقال يتحمل مسؤوليه همم
مذكره تفاهم بين امريكا وبين العراق على
مدى سنتين على ان تقوم هذه المنصه
باجراءات مهمه للحد من عمليه التزوير في
الحوالات او الامور الاخرى اللي يتعلق
بعمليه التحويل الدولار الامريكي اليوم
السيد السوداني فوج بان البنك المركزي لم
يتخذ اجراءات في هذه المنصه المهمه التي
من خلالها يتم عمليه تسجيل الحوالات
لاسترادات العراق من خلال باقي في العراق
الدينار العراقي
ولا زال في انخفاض سبعه % طيب لا من 1480
من 1480 الى
1602 و 20 يعني النسبه هي تتجاوز سبعه
وسته بالعشره لهذه يعني تقارير البنك
المركزي العراقي دكتور عبد الستار ما رايك
في كلام ضيفي ما هو يلقي باللوم اولا على
طريقه تعامل البنك المركز العراقي همم في
داخل العراقي مع كل هذه التطورات وكذلك
الموقف الامريكي كما افهم منه
لا هو تدرين احنا كلنا نتذكر نسيان
الشبيبي في 2012
[موسيقى]
من كان يؤمن باستقلال البنك المركزي
العراقي ومن طلب من عند المالكي 5 مليارات
رفض ينطيه اياه قال البنك ال ال المركز
العراقي بنك مستقله كان يريد يساوي
الدولار بالدينار العراقي كان هذا هدف منه
سنان الشبيبي احنا نتذكر بالله بدي اول
دينار ملكي من كان يساوي خمس دولارات الان
الجماعه وصلوها الى 1600 وربما ما يصل الى
المساله الحقيقه همم في هذه الخطوه اقاله
همم المخيف رغم انه مخيف من القانون
والعوده الى العلاقه يذكرنا ب 2012 يوم
اقيله
جاء لك مسؤول عن تهريب الدولار من اسس
تهريب الدولار في العراق والمالكي الحلاق
والملك عندهم خطه الخطه انه مع هذا احتمال
يروحون الى طبعا جديده نار العراقي اذا ما
قدر البنك بعد يوزع دولارات
اومال يذهبون الى واشنطن لتخفيف الضغط
لمده سته اشهر لماذا لا يتوقف تهريب
الدولار الى ايران والى سوريا والى والى
والى غيرها من الدول بعيدا عن العراقيين
فانا اعتقد المشكله كبيره كلش احنا الان
اما نذهب الى حقبه التسعينيات دور ونذهب
الى نفس الطريقه اللي كان صدام بها عايش
ومعيش العراقيين لان هذول وجه اخر من من
من نفس من نفس التفكير والعقليه ما صدام
حسين راح يرجعونا الى التسعينيات وامها
انه هناك ربما يفتحون المجال لثوره عامه
حقيقه يعني تذيع هؤلاء يعني السلطه لان
هذا وضع بصراحه المواطن سيدفع الغالي
والرخيص ولا
شيئا دكتور عدنان
دكتور عبد الستار الثوره هو قال يمكن ان
تكون هناك احتجاجات عامه لتغيير الطبقه
السياسيه على اثر هذه التطورات هذا ممكن
هل يعتقد هذا الكلام غير المهني لا يموت
للحرفيه بواضح انه بالتاكيد يمكن يصير
تظاهرات ممكن يوم 25 تحت صار المظاهرات
لكن واقع الحال يقول بان هذه الازمه يمكن
ان تطوق بشكل عام في تركيا
العمله التركيه باضعاف في ايران انهارت
العمله الايرانيه في دول عديده في لبنان
نهاره العمله بشكل واسع انا اقول اليوم
العراق يملك خزين من الدولارات السيد همم
السوداني يعرف بان هذه القضيه السياسيه
والتفاهمات مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
سيذهب وفد غدا الى الولايات المتحده العرض
يعني المبادره العراقيه في تنشيط المنصه
من جديد وفسح المجال لعمليه التحويلات الى
الخارج واستبدال السيد علي العلاقه الذي
تمتع بمهنيه واستقلاليه كامله القضيه لا
تتعلق بالسياسه لا مخيف ولا مساله على
قضيه البنك محافظ
وانا كمان دكتور عدنان حتى الاسماء مهمه
كذلك ضيف يقول منذ قليل دكتور عبد الستار
بان مع احترامنا لكل الشخصيات ولكل اسماء
وما قاله على عهده يقول بان الشخص المنصب
في هذه الاسنان هو من همم تحمل مسؤوليه او
هو المسؤول على تراجع سعر صرف الدينار
العراقي في السابق
يعني يعني سيده العزيزه نحن نعلم بان مثل
هكذا كلام يكون كلام غير واقعي لانه لا
يمكن لرئيس الوزراء مع قوه سياسيه تريد
حلل الاشكالات مع احتمال تظاهرات تصير
ياتي بشخص يهرب من دولار يعني خلينا نكون
واقعيين وموضوع
العراقي بس عفوا هاي الكلمه بعد اذنك
خلي يفهم منه العلاق العلاق هو الذي اخرج
الدينار العراقي من منطقه الرماديه اللي
كانت دائما سوداء الى المنطقه الخضراء
وايضا هو كان في سنه 2018 حصل على افضل
محافظ للبنوك المركزيه العربيه
بشهاده واضحه من قبل
نعم
انا اقصد كان 1200 دولار من السلامه
العلاق صار اليوم 1600 هاي اكبر انجاز
للعلاقه واحد اثنين المنصه اللي خلوها
الان المنصه فاجله لان المالك الحقيقي لا
لا لا يكشف عن هويتي ولا عن مصدر اموالهم
يقولون هم موظفوا البنك المركزي العراقي
اخذ اذن لسته اشهر لتخفيف الضغط من البنك
الفدرالي على البنك المركز العراقي لانه
جماعه راح يعني راح انا اقول هزيمه
الميلشات منتظرها في ظل هذا الواقع لان
احنا بصراحه
حول حول هذه الرحله الدكتور عطاني يقول
بانه يشير بان هذا همم هذه القراءه غير
صحيحه
والله يا سيدتي اقول لك كلام دقيق ذولا
جماعه الاسلام السياسي الشيعي حزب الدعوه
ولا كل الاحزاب اللي هم وكلاء ايران ما
عندهم شيء اسمه مهنيه ولا عندهم شيء اسمه
وطنيه لانه من يروحوا النحو الوطني و نحو
الميانيه يفقدون ارتباطهم بالحرس الثوري
ولذلك هم يصرون على اللا مهنيه ولا وطنيه
وهذا انا اعتقد هذه خطوه تصعيد من قبل
السوداني ومن قبل العلاق في ظل ان ايران
ربما تنتظر هجوم عسكري وشيك لذلك المساله
بين امريكا وبين رايحه احنا يجب ان نخلي
هذا بالميزان وجاوب عليه
الدكتور عدنان
هي المنصه بشكل عام وهو مقترح امريكي يعني
هو فرض امريكي وليس عراقيه المنصه تم
الاتفاق بين الجانب العراقي والجانب
الامريكي بناء على يعني قرارات اجراءات
امريكيه سنه 2020 وان يكون خلال سنتين يتم
اعداد هذه المنصه وتدريب العراقيين عليها
وفعلا تم تدريب العراقيين ولكن السيد
الكاظم مع الاسف الشديد ومحافظ بنك
المركزي لن يتخذ الاجراءات المناسبه
لتفعيل هذه المنصه التي تعتبر طريقه
للتفاهم بين البنك
المركزي العراقي بالمناسبه تتعلق بالسياسه
انما هي قضيه ماليه بحته واضح ان هناك
اجراءات ماليه والعراق اليوم من اجل فك
القيود على المساله صرف الدولار الامريكي
شوفي هذا اللي قال مال مخيف اللي جاب مقتل
كاظم والعوده بيه العلاق ما عاد انقلاب
على حكومه الكاظمي حكومه الكاظم التي كانت
تريد ان تعود بالعراق الى محيطه العربي
الجماعه لا رايحين بسرعه الضوء بالاتجاه
المعاكس وها المساله خطيره جدا في عقليه
السياسه مالت الميليشيات المرتبطه بالحرس
وعقليه خامنائي هم رايحين بسرعه الضوء
اتجاه المعاكس وسيرون يعني حصاد سيادتهم
لاحقه طيب خلينا نشوف هذه الزياره واشنطن
ما الذي ستحمل وبعدها سنبقى في متابعه هذا
الملف وهذه التطورات شكرا جزيلا على
المشاركه من همم بغداد الدكتور عدنان سراج
رئيس المركز العراقي لتنميه الاعلاميه ومن
اسطنبول دكتور عمر عبد الستار المحلل
السياسي العراقي شكرا لكم